in five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
the genius brain podcast I'm your host
David Stone we have a very special guest
I've known this [ __ ] for a very
very long time
talented actor extraordinaire dude one
of those people out there then when I
met I was like I respect the [ __ ]
[ __ ] out of you did like was a [ __ ]
cow dude how long have we known each
other for damn dude you know I just I
just had summer on year two and I've yet
and I definitely knew you before I met
her but it's been a long time man
a very [ __ ] long time and I learned
her divorce and everything too on that
last pocket oh damn that's crazy that
must have been oh [ __ ] you're divorced
time flies time [ __ ] flies man it's
so insane man dude like the last time I
I mean the first time I think I really
hung out with you is when you used to
live in that place in k-town yeah yeah
how did I meet you though I have no idea
do you think it was dude Danielle I feel
like Danielle is the reason why I meet
everything Danielle yeah it could be but
what was it for maybe it was for a
sketch or something cuz I know the first
I think the first big sketch we did was
the Nike one I mean at the Nike one the
shoes one yeah that was the bigger one
but then I've known you for a long time
before that though probably through
Justin maybe then maybe that might be
that might be the connecting thing dude
dude man so you finally got on a [ __ ]
show hey Netflix you know what in you
know what people don't know about both
they don't know about the the whole
Nightcrawler situation thing did oh yeah
yeah dude that was insane man that was
cool just going in for things like that
like back in the day and not knowing
what kind of project that would be
become you know what'd you that was a
that was an indie film right uh no my
call it wasn't an indie film it was it
was a pretty big film um it was with
Jake Gyllenhaal yep yeah I went in for
that for a couple times and um yeah it's
it's just it's just crazy to people
don't know is that you actually had the
part right no no no no no what I had the
the part that someone that they gave me
was for Green Dragons oh yeah well my
manager was like yeah you booked it oh
[ __ ]
yeah and I was like okay cool and then I
didn't hear anything like that's just
[ __ ] stuff yeah it's crazy man this
this this the journey like the ups and
downs of being an actor it's just so
it's so crazy they just punch you in the
face and then you're just like alright
just take it yeah man it's like a drive
by a speeding dude yeah dude I had this
uh with this podcast where I was talking
to Megan dia and they're talking about
their whole idea specifically about her
whole acting situation yeah and I think
you know you know hated the actor yes
yes yes so yeah he hit me up and he was
talking to me about the whole just
watching that podcast and he goes man
like this [ __ ] industry is tough you
know and yeah man hearing somebody break
down and talk about the difficulty of
being in being an actor I think for him
it kind of hit a heart string a little
bit it's like you know I don't think
people realize how [ __ ] hard the
shows yeah man I think you just have to
change like your perception about it and
not think about it as like achieving
some kind of end goal you know it is it
is literally just you enjoying the
journey in the process and having a good
time doing it otherwise you're just
gonna like go crazy yeah because it's I
think when you go into acting right like
what is the percentage of people that
really get to pop off at how many roles
are there I just had a conversation to
where there were roles that I went in
for that I got multiple callbacks I got
this [ __ ] close and I was like I wish
I had that show where's the show not
even air yeah and it's crazy and you put
yourself through that rollercoaster of
emotions you're like man would be so
great to to be on that show like man I'd
[ __ ] I didn't get it but then it didn't
even go anywhere and at all yeah
everything that I got a callback for
that was really close to and didn't even
happen nothing happened with it so is
the only thing would be just a nice nice
ass paycheck yeah you know it would be
nice 30 G's boom would you got on -
Lewis asses which was a pretty big
[ __ ] deal for you man because I feel
like you've been grinding for so long
and I think like I think just those
those roles were a solid Asian actor
just I mean how many are those are there
right yeah and this is a show
specifically with all Asian people in it
yeah yeah yeah it's uh it was fun man
just me just me reading the breakdown
and
see what kind of character was I was
just like man I have to do that yeah and
I wasn't originally called in to into
the room someone my friend asked me to
help her tape for the sister role and I
was like yeah sure I'll help you tape it
and then and then she was like yeah you
should um you should talk to your team
about this other part and I looked at
the bottom like dude heroin addict like
um it just all it just hit all the the
you know the cylinders of the kind of
character that I wanted to attack and I
was like man how come how come I'm not
going in for it so I hit up my team and
they're like yeah we we uh we submitted
it we submitted you for it but they're
not calling you in so I'm like okay all
right I'm just gonna I'm just gonna put
myself on tape so myself on tape and I
sent it to my my agents and then they
were like you know what I think it'd be
better if you go in and so they said
they're not gonna send it in they're
just gonna talk harder to the casting
directors and be like yo let's do you
you guys should really see this guy
because they saw the tape mm-hmm and so
I finally went in and um yeah that's
crazy so you won't even call them for
the audition at all
damn dude so you wanted that role that I
wanted it so bad
super bad that's [ __ ] crazy man it's
so weird though because I feel you know
with the whole acting process that part
there's certain roles that you really
[ __ ] want you know and sex when you
finally have a role that really
resonates with you and you don't get it
and then you see the person that gets
them like yes son of a [ __ ] I see when
the [ __ ] streets [ __ ] out and the
only thing you can do is like yeah yeah
you know I wish him the best man I hope
he does good but deep down inside your
life you're a lot nicer than me I'm like
I wish the worst apparent you were going
to destroy this role and it should have
went to me you [ __ ] [ __ ] man it's
hard to play at a Tonya Harding them
[ __ ] deal with that and he's a wolf or
a [ __ ] person in a wheelchair just
higher Khalif Cleve [ __ ] kick his ass
sperm yeah I know it's hard man like I
think that you know when I first started
doing the whole acting thing for the
year because I really wanted to figure
out how what it was like yeah [ __ ]
that's not easy
I don't know how you've been doing it
for so long because you know I I love
doing it you know I think like it takes
a certain kind of person you know like
you know you you you might have to have
like some kind of masochistic kind of
personality yeah you know to go through
you know the ups and downs and I don't
know I like it you like I like it you
know I feel like the job isn't
necessarily the job it is like the
process of trying to get it mmm not that
that's sort of what excites me you know
when there's like when there are
droughts and I'm not doing anything he
for some reason I like it a little bit
mm-hmm so weird kind of feeling
it's that it's that hunger Philly right
yeah make sure you have some pushed or
something yeah and if it was easy yeah I
don't know if I would like it so much
you know if it was like you know people
say like you know is your hard like
being asian-american like with like all
this lack of representation and whatnot
and I'm like yeah yeah it is but then
like if it was given to me like so
easily I don't know if I would like it
so much I sort of like this challenge
it's fun
yeah like navigating this whole system I
don't think you've ever fallen into that
category of somebody who who's ever put
it on their ethnicity for a reason why
you never got to book a role right now I
know and I've always hated that attitude
too cuz I've I've heard that so often
specifically in this industry they go oh
I didn't book it because they don't want
people who look like me in this role but
at the same time I mean not gonna call
it any names but I see some of the
people who have been complaining the
loudest I'm like you're the worst actor
I've ever seen in my life
oh [ __ ] dare you and you know it's
funny it might be the case but then like
just even saying that out loud for
yourself as an artist it just hinders
you from like you know doing better work
yeah you know you just you justify it by
saying oh yeah they they didn't they
didn't cast me because they didn't want
an Asian guy they went in another
ethnicity yeah or maybe they just didn't
catch you because you weren't the right
part for it you weren't good enough yeah
I know I think that's a it's a more
rational way for me to think things
because if I keep thinking it's about
something that's out of my control then
it makes me go crazy
yeah like what's the point yeah totally
it's such a hard thing to deal with too
it's just like oh it's because I'm Asian
but I would like to hear that from
people who I respect
a little more though yeah you know cuz I
think the people who are booking who do
great things and you look at them and
they're respected in their craft I don't
ever hear them say that [ __ ] and there's
a reason why they're booking I think
Justin said it the best - he goes you
know he goes I don't really like to play
this game he goes I just try to get
booked based on my skill yeah so cuz if
the skill is there it's gonna eventually
it'll become undeniable eventually it'll
hit something you know I mean when
before you were before you hit this this
big roll on a big series I mean what's
it what's it kind of like I think as an
actor too because people want to go into
this profession what's it like kind of
dealing with not not being able to book
right because I feel like that's a
majority of the acting game is is its
number one to study your craft in the
waiting game yeah I did you just gotta
figure out you know what to do during
that time and it literally is just
continuing to work on your [ __ ] you know
if you think like oh man I don't think
it should be a waiting game and I think
once people start thinking of it like
they're waiting then nothing will come
but if you'll just keep yourself busy
you don't work on other things and just
try to get better take a class I mean I
think it's just like it's it's it's
working out a muscle man do you ever
like doubt your skill oh yeah for sure
all the time man
but the thing is that that that what
I've learned though is that you got to
use that hmm and use that doubt and put
it into the character and you start
working on that character as a doubtful
character hmm then that doubt creeps in
as something that's a part of who a part
of that part of that part of that person
you know and so people can't really see
that and you sort of like sort of just
uh bring it in and put it into the story
and I feel like that has really helped
yeah maybe maybe because you deal with
this so well because like there's some
other people I think that when because
it's such it's it's a career where you
do you are constantly looking for
affirmation all the time yeah and you
don't even get the tips to why you can't
even book some of these roles so you
you're kind of left feeling lost all the
time right and so it's like how do you
become that person where
still stay confident in your choices
after you leave an audition yeah as I
think that's the first thing that
happens to a lot of people who go into
this they go oh I thought I did really
well what the [ __ ] is it and they switch
up their game plan
yeah they carts they start switching
things they start thinking like what do
they want you start doing things that
they think other people want to see but
I feel like if you really believe in
what you're bringing to the story then
there's no need to think about anything
else and how you should do things
differently because you never know why
they're gonna buy why they're gonna book
you you know you just got to go in and
just be very steadfast in your
capability know and just try to get
better and better not not try to
navigate the system and try to do better
so that they'll pick you because if you
keep doing that you're just gonna keep
missing I believe like you just have to
go in like yo this is what I believe the
story is this is what I believe um you
know how the how the character would be
in this kind of situation and then you
just present that to them yeah if
somebody was trying to be an an actor
let's say like out of the blue what
would be like what would be like a
couple of things you would tell somebody
in order to be like successful and
survive in this industry was something
that you would tell them man I think
it's just you just got to be very
persistent man and you got a you got to
work at it it's not something it's not
about like you know it it's different
from other kinds of art because it's not
really a performance mmm you know you're
not going in there and doing like this
like this is a performance you really
have to become you really have to become
these characters so you got to really
work on I guess you got to work on you
got to go take a class man like it's not
something that is just like oh I'm gonna
be an actor and then some some people
some people become successful that way
and they hit like one big thing but then
I feel like oh like over time you know
it's it's it's gonna expire and I feel
like if you really want to do something
like this you just got to work on your
craft man that's that's pretty much the
the biggest thing I think you know and I
feel like some people think it's just so
easy you know it's like it's like it's
like tell it's like someone saying like
oh I want to be a doctor and then they
go and they think they can be a doctor
like the next week
I you know I get really annoyed when
somebody does that to like like for
example I don't know how many times I
met somebody when they go dude I got
this great script idea I'm like listen
to me shut the [ __ ] like III I don't
want to hear like I really don't not to
say that maybe your script idea isn't
great but they kind of I want people to
understand that when you tell that to
somebody who is I'm not a script writer
screenwriter right but when you told
that to somebody who's a screenwriter
that has worked their ass off to be
where they're at right and you go I have
something that the world hasn't seen yet
and I'm gonna do something better than
you it's like okay out of all the people
in the world why is it that it would be
you I'm not telling you to self doubt
yourself but have a little bit of
self-awareness because I think people
they kind of don't understand how
difficult it is to either sell a TV show
to get a movie made and have it be
really good and they not without knowing
that they kind of they're your
lightweight looking you're kind of like
what's the word I'm looking for you guys
are not being mindful of how the work
and dedication it takes to be in that
career yeah it's true man self-awareness
is very key yeah you know what's funny
though is when anyone starts off though
doing any kind of like artistic thing I
think that's sort of what propels them
at first though cuz they think they can
do it they're like [ __ ] yeah I got this
I want to be an actor I can do this and
it's just that just it's just being a
naive just a little bit but then tip it
but once they tip they're dipped their
toes into the field and they realize how
crazy it is then that's when they should
start you know working towards um I
don't know getting better at what
they're doing yeah you know what I mean
but sometimes you know in the beginning
it sort of helps them over you know like
it's just like in ignorance yeah
you know you're like yeah I'm a [ __ ]
like you know I can be a dancer I like
music my body you know like but that's
what propels people to do stuff yeah and
you know I admire that at first but but
you know over time you know you got to
realize that you know there there are so
many other
there's so many other things that that
that come into play yeah you know and
even even as an actor too it's like like
but why do you want to do in the first
place you know is it because you want to
be famous you want attention like if
those are the things that drive you then
you know you got to really sit back and
really think about like what is it why
am I doing this
this podcast is brought to you by Sunday
scary's my firend Sunday scary is a
leader in the CBD space they have
created a niche for themselves by
addressing America's anxiety problem
they sell wildly effective and delicious
tasting CBD products especially their
CBD gummies if you guys have not has CBD
products before number one there's no
reason to be scared of it it's something
that I've been using for about two and a
half years I don't use anything with CBD
and THC in it I like to use CBD products
to help me calm down and relax there is
no head change there's no psychoactive
properties about it so it really gets me
to just it helps me relax in a couple of
ways for me I started using CBD products
because I had a little bit of anxiety
not in the anxiety that you would
probably typically see like on
television or whatever but there are
moments where sometimes my work gets so
so busy I get really just kind of heady
with my stuff meaning that I overthink
things I start to stress out so I
started using CBD products just to put
me in a better mental space and it has
been helping out a lot it also helps a
lot in sparring surprisingly when before
I spar I'm overthinking my moves and so
I'll take a couple of CBD gummies and it
helps me just chill out a little bit
relax without the head change and and I
love it man like it's it's a necessity
for me so I've been using CBD products
for a very long time now apparently
which I didn't know that two and a half
years is is a pretty long time for
people who don't really know about it
and I love it Madness it's an everyday
thing for me so check it out if you want
to get 15% off all you have to do is use
your code brain at Sunday scariest calm
and stop dreading the everyday [ __ ]
in life that doesn't actually matter
remember if you want to get 15% off use
the code brain at Sunday scary calm and
stop dreading
everyday [ __ ] in life that doesn't
actually matter Sunday scary's baby I
think all that [ __ ] fades too after a
while cuz you're just left with the
craft at that point because once you
stop booking you stop doing all the
stuff you say well why am i why am I
still doing this what's the whole point
yeah you know and even to when it comes
to fame as you get older there's people
that are gonna be popping off when
they're younger and then when they're
older they're not booking these same
roles anymore because their age they may
need younger and fresher faces that what
are you left with then are you okay with
the legacy that you left behind and can
you be happy looking back at that or are
you still gonna be searching for that
validation from other people and I think
that's where people get really [ __ ] up
right
and it's important what you said - it's
the why behind a lot of things yeah why
are you really [ __ ] doing this that's
why I want to hear the script stuff it's
like I'm like oh that's dope that's cool
but my point is that I want people to
also understand you're not the first
person that said that you are one out of
a million people right it's great that
you have that belief but also stay
grounded enough to know that you it just
might not pop off you may think that
your story is great and unique maybe it
isn't
yeah maybe you don't know how to tell
that story because script writing for
most people that don't understand it's
very [ __ ] difficult it's hard and
then you wrote the script in a week and
you present it to somebody who is a
screenwriter and you go you know this is
the [ __ ] right here and then when they
tell them this isn't it they go you know
you don't know what's up you come into
advice for them and yeah like you just
need you need the humility behind behind
everything man beforehand yeah you went
to you were did you go to high school
this summer is that how you yeah I'm
gonna high school was summer would you
guys weren't the-- we were sure I wasn't
necessarily in theater but the theater
program allowed students to audition for
like sketches Oh after school and then
all the plays that they put up were they
allowed everyone on campus to audition
for them yes so then I wasn't
necessarily like um taking drama classes
but I was very involved in what they
were doing oh yeah how come you never
took the class I don't know I just never
dude that was just like I
I was doing band I was running
cross-country
oh shoot another [ __ ] and but you know I
should have when I think about I'm like
why didn't I do that but I feel like um
I feel like doing all the after-school
things and then participating in the
plays and stuff I felt like that was
already pretty like it helped me a lot I
feel like if I was gonna if I were to
take the classes it would be more like I
guess like an English major like reading
a lot of plays and like analyzing plays
so you took that skill and then you
decided to go into acting or something
acting if you always wanted to do no it
was it definitely wasn't it was just it
just came out of nowhere like my friend
was just like oh you should um she
audition for these plays with me after
school and I did it I felt like random
yeah I felt like you know like you know
when you're growing up he's sort of
trying to find your identity and then
back in the day like early 2000s late
90s just a bunch of like Asian gangsters
walking around frontin and [ __ ] and
you're trying to like figure out is that
what I want to do like I you know I felt
like the beginning of my high school
years was just filled with me like like
hanging out with these guys and trying
to be tough and I sort of wanted to
juxtapose that like like towards the end
of my high school you know towards the
end of high school and I felt like by
doing that was just to not care about
what other people thought about me and
and I feel like the fastest route
towards that was like doing these stupid
plays mmm that you know he was just
saying stupid [ __ ] on stage and not
really caring and that's sort of I felt
like opened me up and sort of helped me
like forget like you know my past
identity and just try to create a new
one that I I didn't know and that I
didn't know what it was and just like go
from there and that was the interesting
thing for me in high school to I think
the the the best time I've ever had in
high school was towards the end of my
junior and senior year when I was like
here what [ __ ] you yeah you know that's
what I doing choir yeah I'm gonna join
choir yeah dude am i you now man your
voice your you've got a beautiful voice
man
did you always sing like ever since you
were a kid or like nah man I thought I
mean with lack of a better word at the
time I thought that [ __ ] was gay only
because other people made me feel that
way
yeah yeah I know I like singing I like
singing in the shower yeah I used to
practice some [ __ ] I remember my brother
used to make fun of me because I was
saying all the time right and it made me
feel ashamed of it right like hold on a
second man dude there's RB singers out
there dude like why am i ashamed about
this thing and I never thought I was a
good singer I remember I the first
notion of me even being be able to sing
on key was when I went camping with my
cousin and then we just had some music
on and I was singing along to it he's
like bro you could sing and I was like
right I don't know because I never
recorded myself Yeah right
and even when I did record myself I
didn't like my voice yeah like it's
whatever and I think I've always just
been a hyper critical kid uh-huh I was
like I it's whatever and then I Nord it
the whole time and I've always wanted to
join choir for the longest [ __ ] time
even since my sophomore year I never did
it I was like god I wish I would do all
that [ __ ] and I just never did and then
lo and behold it turns out that ladies
actually like it when you sing yeah yeah
guitar [ __ ] that's like oh okay so I'm
going to the right route and then I
decided to inquire I think it was the
the last trimester of my junior year and
then I went to choir again my senior
year and then I won this [ __ ] nope I
don't know like I didn't get a lot of
awards in high school but I got this
music award for it for don't inquire and
I didn't realize like I was a great
singer until or a decent singer until I
got an award and oh I might be that's
awesome so that's what sort of when you
realize oh wow I'm [ __ ] good yeah at
least people think I am yeah and I was
like I am I I had no idea that I had
either a knack for it and after a while
to like that my passion for music died a
bit and I think it was because once it
started to become something that I think
I was trying to get recognized for it
took the magic out of it mm-hmm totally
it was just supposed to be something
that was fun yeah and I never wanted to
make it into a career that always takes
a magic out of everything you realize
that once you if you continue to do
things for fun that's when
that's when the genius sort of hits all
the time that's what it is with this
YouTube you know um when I was doing it
for fun is when I had the best content
and then after a while the platform
started to become something where it was
about as much views as you can get no
matter what the content is no matter
what your voices do whatever you can to
get out on top yeah
now people who have done it really well
they made a lot of [ __ ] money and
they made the money in their bounce or
they're still making a lot of money
right now but I've never been able to
switch that on rom might yield this is a
[ __ ] business make the business work
yeah because it just this is not where I
wanted to make money that's not how it
started off it started off as something
that I was going to do to make my
stand-up comedy pop off and so I used it
to tour a lot do stand-up so when I
first started doing YouTube all these
college shows started coming up I'm like
dude I'm gonna knock out the stand-up
[ __ ] so I would do during like the
stand-up season I would hit the clubs
and then I would go on these these
college tours and it was the most fun
I've ever had doing stand-up and after a
while I found out that that started to
die for me - mm-hmm you know I was like
okay well if this is not the gold then
what's the whole point of having YouTube
and I was gonna quit youtube I was I'm
just gonna toss it away I didn't like
the title of being a youtuber at the
time because you know back in the day
being a youtuber was kind of looked down
upon it's like in the mainstream
industry yeah yeah you're a youtuber
you're not a real acting on a real comic
and I used to piss me off
because I came from stand-up I was a
stand-up comic I tried to extend his I
was like 16 yeah and so when I came on
the scene I remember I did this the show
and I was there was like four headliners
and they put me on there because I had a
following and everybody had their name
ba ba ba comic stand-up comic stand-up
comic in my name you to her know and I
know I know they did that to piss me off
did you talk about it in your set I
didn't talk about in my set I just
killed the set yeah like I just I
[ __ ] destroyed that [ __ ] I murdered
that [ __ ] and so and I remembered this
because there was a dude that came up
that pissed me off
- no [ __ ] end and he basically said
Oh bro like man I'm probably gonna
slaughter this own story cuz happened so
long ago
but he was basically it was basically
along the lines of him saying like oh yo
how long have you been doing this stand
of stuff always all you do you to
stuff right and you could tell this a
little bit of like you know something to
it like yeah he goes yeah I've been
doing standing for like you know like
like three years no so if you want
advice you know before you hit the stage
let me know and I was like that's cool
I've been doing since I was 16 so you
let me know when you want to buy some
[ __ ] like that I said with something way
more rude man he goes up he bombs
terrible stand the [ __ ] worst right I
go up after him I destroyed the [ __ ]
set and basically I was like [ __ ] you
right and so I had like this huge chip
on my shoulder about that I think that
was the biggest reason why I still
wanted to produce pursue stand-up even
after the magic that yeah but because I
got tired of people looking down on me
about something that they thought they
needed better than me so after that I
kind of figured that oh the reason why
I'm doing stuff is well what what I can
ended up coming to a realization was I
actually like just entertaining no
matter what it is I like creating things
with my own hands whether that's why we
I did Guk is that because I want to be
an actor it's just I like this everyone
working together and working with your
friends got to work with my friends I
was super passionate about it you know a
fat Chum that was my personal life story
that they got to see so it was it was a
really fun project and then people got
it in their mind they're like oh you're
gonna be a great actor I'm not I never
said I wanted to be an actor you know I
did my piece like I'll I'll still do it
but I'm not putting in the time to be an
actor I'm not taking acting classes like
you're so good in it thanks man
and um I don't know if I'm gonna get
better act at acting unless I put the
time into it like that's where I'm at
and I'm probably not even as good as
that because Justin worked with me for
like a month before we shot the film so
now it's like if I want to go into that
role of being an actor I got to dive
back in I showed everything down when I
did the acting thing yeah I stopped
doing YouTube I stopped doing shows I
stopped taking money I was losing money
like a [ __ ] I think it was
necessary that man you know just for you
to tap into it and see if you really
wanted to do it you know what I mean
like if it really made you happy yeah it
took me a year to figure it out and I
love acting I love the craft but I know
that there's something missing that
doesn't allow me to dive into it all the
way you know what I mean is that passion
it's that thing of I can go into every
audition and not book and I'm still
gonna work on this craft and I'm still
gonna go at it and I feel like if I'm
not gonna do that I'm just gonna be
miserable trying
stuff out so I mean I'm still
auditioning I'm still doing that because
that route is still there but I'm not at
that point yet where I can be like you
where I'm like this is it for me mm-hmm
I got a dive in I got to take these
classes and courses which I think it's
very [ __ ] necessary you know yeah
yeah because I think that the the hard
part is even when acting when people
like I want to be an actor they don't
realize what it takes as well yeah right
it's a lot man just like sitting in your
room thinking about thinking about you
crazy
you ever I feel like I'm a hater
sometimes about sometimes I see those
people in the book I'm like damn you and
it makes me feel like man I should go
back in there that's sort of what pushes
you man when people are like you know
what like you know let me give you a few
tips and they go and bomb you're like
dude [ __ ] you [ __ ] proof I'm a
spiteful human being even even like
doing good say why'd you do good is cuz
no agent wanted to assign me yeah it's
like oh you don't think I can add let me
let me drop everything real quick and I
[ __ ] tossed everything aside and I did
it you know I wonder if this is how your
fiance makes you do things no she's like
I think it's like this so I'm gonna try
this route
yeah like yo you don't know how to clean
carpets all I can't clean I become an
apprentice somewhere you're so good at
that though like if someone says like yo
do this you can or if someone says you
can't do this you'll figure that [ __ ]
out yeah I don't know what that is about
it's it's it's definitely like a mental
flaw
there's no that's a good thing man even
even like with like we tie right yeah
it's like people don't know but I did
tech wonder when I was a kid yeah I was
pretty decent at it and then I did more
tie a little bit when I was 20 but then
everybody I don't know what it is but I
think people doing like Oh even like the
compliment started bothering me a little
bit because they're like oh David man if
you put your mind you could do anything
it's like [ __ ] I've been doing yeah
yeah yeah do this gym right now and
let's [ __ ] go right arguably the
puppy might kick my ass David you're so
good yeah [ __ ] is that supposed to mean
that's why when I go in and spar and
then I'm not great at it but there's a
lot of people who think they're great at
something but they don't know how shitty
they are yeah the difference between me
is that I know that I'm not
at this and I'm gonna figure out a way
you're still gonna be better than that
I'm gonna figure out a way to get good
though yeah I think being humble about
your [ __ ] and knowing where you're at
really does help you improve
III believe that man and I think it
really is like you if that's that's
about anything to like it's like not
getting so excited about like being good
at something and not not not thinking so
much about being bad at something like
just not thinking anything I think yeah
even when you hear good news about
something or compliments like oh you're
still good at that like just sort of
throw it away yeah that's that's those
things can actually deter you from
getting better yeah I feel because I I
think that my coach Nikki says something
that's good and bad is that every time I
leave a training session I'm never
satisfied I'm like damn I [ __ ] suck
today I'm not saying that so I'm fishing
for a compliment
I see hey really feel like every [ __ ]
mistake that I've made I lean back too
much my chin was up my right hand was
[ __ ] down I got tagged six seven
times I count him and he's like he goes
you say no you did great that I'm gonna
the [ __ ] are you talking about kidding
and I get mad and I go home and I'm
pissed and I try to get better all the
time
and I'm probably won't ever get really
great at the sport but it's nice to know
that I have something to look forward to
cuz yeah yeah everything's a game of
inches you know totally I agree cuz
you're all you also dance which is
what's by the way always throws me off
that's right cuz you don't you don't
show it as much up until maybe recently
well you maybe started getting a little
more passionate about yeah I think it's
it's literally only when I went when I
feel like doing it sometimes I just have
the itch to do it I'm like man I wanted
to answer right now yeah you know I'll
just do it and um yeah I just think it's
a it's it's an expression that I sort of
threw away when I was younger it was
just like man this thing's taken away
from my acting you know I just need to
set that aside and just go to LA and
start auditioning for things and I just
sort of like put it in a little box and
I set it aside instead of like letting
it be what it was and just improving it
yeah you know like not take everything
so like [ __ ] seriously you know and
you think that helped you out a lot in
acting and everything else it's just to
be like have fun with this [ __ ] totally
man totally it's really understanding
like the root of why I'm doing these
things in the first place if the root is
just to tell the story and have people
empathize with these characters that
they don't normally encounter or that
they do encounter in real life and they
think negatively towards like then you
know then that that is just the goal you
know what I mean and if I'm having fun
doing that and nothing else really
matters you know if I don't if I don't
book something whatever you know
something's gonna come up later you know
where something hits but you know it's
just yeah not really thinking too much
about it yeah not really being too down
either but not route not getting so
excited about good news either it's just
it is what it is and it it's kind of odd
when people have a perception of what
success is in this in this industry
because when you book one thing they go
hi you've made it yeah mate yeah yeah
yeah not at all made what like what are
you talking about I haven't done [ __ ]
yet yeah it's crazy analyzing just like
how I think about like my life - I
remember like thinking man if I just
booked a series I'm gonna be so happy
I'd be like the happiest person like you
know I won't stress out over like like
stupid [ __ ] that I stress out about and
and I remember like just being in
Vancouver shooting and then I was just
you know thinking about how how I was
thinking in that moment and I was like
man I I feel the exact same thing you
know I feel like regardless of this gig
being taken away or given to me like I
would feel the same and it really is
just accepting that feeling of where I
am in that moment and just going with
that and not trying to like reach for
something else or or like make myself
feel bad for not getting something you
know just just to be an acceptance yeah
yeah but you know I'm still working on
that now but I feel like that's that's
where I'm at this podcast is brought to
you by native my friends I love this
deodorant people out there if you think
that you don't need deodorant because
you don't have B oh you would be deathly
wrong I travel a lot and I know a lot of
you people stink like hell out there and
guess what a lot of the products that
you use that you put on your body do you
guys realize
that there's like aluminum and parabens
in in native doesn't have any of that
stuff and you're not sacrificing quality
and performance in a product with native
because just cuz you take that stuff out
you sometimes you think like yo it's
it's not gonna work that well no native
my friends is my go-to deodorant right
now I have actually used as my favorite
is this one right here it's the cucumber
mint the reason why I like this it just
smells really good and fresh and the
cucumber mint smell it could be for a
guy or a girl I I put my life on that
this is my go-to deodorant when I go
train Muay Thai or if I know that I'm
gonna be on the go and it's a hot day
and I can't freshen up this native
deodorant stays in my bag 24/7 and I
love it it's a little bit of something
just for everyone yes my friends believe
that so check it out for 20% off your
first purchase visit native deodorant
calm and use promo code GB during
checkout once again for 20% off your
first purchase visit native deodorant
calm and use promo code GB during
checkout to get that big discount and
start smelling fresh today
native yeah and that that's really
important to say too cuz I think that
just shows that there's you understand
that there's so much more to be had than
than just this because when you are at
the beginning of your career you're
thinking that's your highest goal but
then you stayed here you became a season
back there now it's like oh there's more
to this than that
cuz I'm pretty sure when somebody says
like dude if I just win one Oscar I will
be set for the rest of my life but they
get that one and they go I need another
one no I need I need to do my own film
now I need to direct there's so many
different different like avenues that
you can go to and it doesn't just stop
so yet it's unending and it's infinite
just keeps going but that makes sense
too because that's I think that's what's
exciting about life right yeah you you
just it just there's always something to
explore or become better at yeah but we
just can't let those like reaching those
things be like what makes us happy mm
you know we're obtaining those things I
feel the fight is hard to sometimes like
navigate yourself through this industry
because I think that because I didn't
grow up wanting to be entertainer I
never really glorified everything that
came along with it right I you know put
it simply like [ __ ] mug like money
drugs and [ __ ] like that yeah that
never became glorified in my head so it
doesn't affect me I think that I think
how it affects a lot of other people
that I'm seeing I see a lot of people
too like that they came from a small
town they come into the city and they
have a perception of what Los Angeles is
and they get caught up into that
[ __ ] like they start they start
partying every [ __ ] night they're
getting drunk that [ __ ] drug the [ __ ]
out all the time in my yo what the [ __ ]
happened and it's like [ __ ] that you
get caught up in so [ __ ] easily yeah
and it's just that we're perception of
Hollywood that kind of [ __ ] with you
and I think I got really blessed because
I never really cared for that stuff yeah
I never really got to affect me yeah
yeah that's good cuz I've definitely
dived into those like dived into that
but not because like that was like the
perception of what it would be to like
be in this kind of environment it is
just like hanging out with friends it's
just doing [ __ ] up [ __ ]
yeah and but you know slowly trying to
not do that anymore it's hard though
isn't it it is man especially in this
industry too when like um sometimes
there's a lot of you know the waiting
game is so crazy you know and it's it's
hard to keep yourself so busy all the
time and so sometimes it's just you know
you you you get led astray and then you
just start doing stupid [ __ ] that's hard
man like I think I'm maybe it's because
I did a lot of dumb [ __ ] when I was
younger yeah I think I got it really out
of my awesome cuz people asked is I yo
man room the first time you started
drinking I was like yeah man 13 was
crazy 13 14 is like 13 or 14 years old
people were people were nuts man like I
remember being in like 6 was just 6th
grade and then might like my friend was
like yeah I took some ecstasy the night
before I'm like sixth grade yeah dude I
don't even know what that was at that
time and now knowing what it is it's
like how would your mind even like it
[ __ ] certain process it's the same
there's a lot of people who did I think
drugs when they were younger and I see
that the effects on it now they did it
like hard
not time I every now and then yeah and
they're there they're [ __ ] that dude
I don't know what it is and I might be
reading too much into it but their
thoughts are a little latent like
there's like a lag yeah you gotta weigh
in sketch about that I got better people
have like the loading times before they
reply oh for sure they got this weird
like brain thing going on and I'm kind
of glad that I didn't have the curiosity
to really want to try that stuff yeah I
mean I got drunk and I don't think
because when I was younger I could hold
my liquor very well yeah in your Korean
and I'm Korean so supportive but I never
really liked was into like like doing
coke ecstasy weed all the other [ __ ]
even though everybody else did it I
wasn't interested yeah people are like
oh what was your moral stance on that I
was like I know moral stance I just
wasn't interested yeah no not really
want don't really want to do that yeah
it wasn't anything like oh man those are
for losers I'm just like it doesn't seem
that fun yeah I wish it was some other
story but the the other the only reason
was like me yeah I think it's good not
to tap into that man yeah probably do I
I wasn't demo recently and I took a
edible yeah and um damn weed and I we
don't match I think we talked about this
too before like yeah I can't do that and
socialize
I can't yeah I just be like like it'd be
funny if we did this right now and if we
were both high I would just like yeah it
would be [ __ ] podcast on earth yeah
I'd be like what'd you say Dave I don't
know what you meant by that I don't know
how people say when they're [ __ ] high
dude my own thoughts
yeah and then I don't don't disturb me
and sometimes when people disturb me
then I just start getting paranoid about
why did that guy say that yeah what was
it that what did I do something and then
it's just like you know on this weird
back and forth I think it's also because
I'm a control freak
so when I get high I I don't like it
right because I want to be in control of
my own situation yeah so when I'm when I
have a thought and I want to say
something and it doesn't come out it
starts to frustrate me they're like oh
you're having like you're getting
paranoid it's not paranoid I'm getting
pissed yeah I just don't know how to
fighting express how I'm really feeling
yeah they're like you get this when
you're high I'm [ __ ] so I'm you
sinner just upset and I'm like I'm
supposed to say something really smart
but
so I'm just cities I went out in
happening I'm just gonna eat some chips
yeah and understand that I'm just like
dude you look so dead that's the
difference about being drunk though
drunk it's like you think you are in
control but you think you're in command
you know I'm like I'm about to make the
best choice of my life right now
and that's why I think that's why I like
being drunk but I don't I don't actually
mix well with alcohol because I get a
migraine idea I didn't know that that's
not what's supposed to happen hmm I
thought everybody got that [ __ ] getting
migraines when you're drunk yeah no I
don't think so
yeah because I get super or flush and
red yeah I get a throbbing headache you
ever take a pep said before you drink
does it work dude it works for me man
I swear and it works so in a way we're
like I don't feel I don't know that I
don't feel like the migraine or like the
craziness I think it takes that away to
you how many do you have to take it I
stick one one right there right
beforehand or like maybe 30 you try it
on your next 10 foods oh for sure yeah
just try it try 30 minutes before okay
I'm gonna take a Pepsi because I do like
the taste of alcohol alcohol is amazing
man yeah I like I like I I didn't use to
like beer I was to talk mad [ __ ] about
people who didn't like beer but one
[ __ ] day I started I like beer and
coffee together at the same time I was
like what the [ __ ] and asked my mom I
didn't ask we were having a conversation
as a mom guess what I kind of like now I
was like I kind of like the taste of
coffee and beer she goes you know why
when you get older life gets better so
you like bitter that's funny yeah smart
mom I started liking beer and I was like
yo this this stuff actually tastes
pretty [ __ ] good yeah I don't know
why you know what I've never liked the
taste of alcohol I just can't and I just
like how alcohol makes me feel so like
whenever I'm drinking something
everyone's telling me like always swig
it in your mouth or taste it I'm like no
[ __ ] it I'm just gonna down even for
beer to like if I get a beer I'm just I
try to drink it down as fast as I can
I don't even try to enjoy the taste I
just I guess I don't have like an
elevated palate like even for wine like
I don't know [ __ ] about anything man
it's just so hard you know it's funny
people are like what's your favorite
wine and I was like whichever one tastes
more like juice and they're like nah man
you gotta do you taste the earthy grassy
notes as if it was as if it was a fresh
tulip that was picked in the mid
point of spring during the hottest day
where a river came down and the minerals
from the river actually gave the
nutrients to the grape and I'm like shut
during that time there was a war there's
blood sprinkled on the soil the taste of
these grapes and now what you're tasting
is aids
thank you I get cool things yeah cuz
I've had like a really a jewel of wine
and it tastes in I was like what is this
and so I was watching a documentary
about wine and how this how does someone
you put it was honestly if you don't
like whining you don't know what you're
looking for these expensive wines if you
like it I'd be surprised yeah yeah I
would be surprised he goes go for a
bottle that you like and you like the
way that it tastes and stick with it
don't worry about the price yeah drink
it and say I like this then stick with
that yeah and then stop trying to like
impress people by being like yeah I know
this kind of wine and then there's being
all like smartass about that's why when
we're doing send foods when we have a
wine tasting let's go all right man it
tastes it tastes wine that's so funny
do you guys did you guys ever eat
something and you're like aha that was
not good
Oh bro the original sin food we're
talking trash about a lot of [ __ ] but I
think there are a little more
consciousness out you know once we got
bought out we're not upsetting people
yeah we have to be mindful of that [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah yeah okay I'll be really
my mom so you guys lie I want to say I
lie per se because the chef is right
there staring into my spirit dude that's
so hard man cuz if something doesn't
really taste good what do you say I mean
for me I just I just talk about what's
wrong with it
mm-hmm but then they're all you talk
about the positives - yeah like it's
food it's edible
yeah you know it comes out as poop
eventually holy things I could really
say but people can tell when we dislike
something yeah really
like something man yeah yeah and that's
the thing like when we talk about why
Nishat - there's a lot of [ __ ] beer
though like you could really taste the
difference in beer mm-hmm like I don't
know from this Pilsner to that Pilsner
but the different types of beer have a
very different taste it's like having
like apple - an orange you could tell
the difference between an apple and an
orange totally I definitely don't like
dark ales
yeah darker beers or like IPAs
I don't like IPAs I like stouts though
you know
the Guinness dark Aspie yeah it's like
coffee yeah yeah yeah I like the taste
of [ __ ] no did they do that they have
that right coffee would be R oh dude
that I had just like we went in in sin
foods we went to this brewery and
they're the ones that do the allagash
[ __ ] allagash whites which i think like
that's a great introductory beer if you
don't like beer at all and it's very
taste like oranges you know has that
citrus and that's why people they
squeeze [ __ ] oranges in there and it
tastes really good but they had
different types of beer where it was one
was aged in a whiskey barrel so it
tasted like aged wood and whiskey which
was a very interesting flavor there was
another one that tastes like cherries
there was a yeah there was another one
that tasted like oh it was a bourbon
barrel yes she and beer there's more
apparent taste yeah like in wine it's
like I don't know man
exactly there's no I am - yeah I think
if we have more wine then maybe we might
be able to tell ya I don't care enough -
yeah yeah yeah yeah you know you'll only
start caring if someone's like David you
don't know [ __ ] about one horseshit
about wine than you do that's something
you don't know about was like yeah but I
know the inside of your mom's [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know why it's because wine
when some sometimes when people talk
about lying to me I think that they use
it as a way to be a little snobby about
she totally you know I can't just like
like me I hate it when I have a wine I'm
like oh that's good they're like oh you
don't know what the good stuff is I will
suck my [ __ ] nuts how about that suck
my [ __ ] nuts I will drink whatever
the [ __ ] I want
and it's just that's the part where it's
almost like are you looking down at me
cuz I know about aged juice [ __ ] like
it's rotten juice don't tell me what I
don't know about this wine I'm okay
enjoying my [ __ ] you know dude speaking
of alcohol I was in New York right
before you came and I was at this place
and I really legitimately feel like I
got roofied your special bro like I
don't know what it was but I literally I
don't think I've ever like blacked out
and in that kind of way ever before and
I was remembering how much I was
drinking too
all I all I remember is just like boom
waking up in my oh [ __ ] day just like
the [ __ ] and then my friend sent me all
these videos like yo I was looking for
you for like a couple couple hours to
two and a half hours trying to find you
and you kept saying like no it's okay
leave me here I'm fine and then my
friend walked me back home and just
showed me videos of me walking home and
then she was like yeah like we couldn't
find you but we finally found you and
then and then and then when it when I
look at the videos I'm like that's not
me that's so weird
and it was a place called the box have
you heard of the Box smart so they
usually do these like burlesque shows
but then they're like really bizarre
they didn't do the show the night that
we went but supposedly you go and then
you watch like like a ballerina will
come out mmm and then show you the
cupcake and then she'll like diarrhea it
out and then she'll eat it and she'll
throw it up
what the [ __ ] or like a dude with tits
will just like um like jerk off and like
light a firework what yeah it's called
the box they have one in London they
have one in New York
that's [ __ ] wild but they didn't but
there was nothing there there were no
shows at night yeah at least I do not
recall yeah and it's just a weird place
to begin with so I could see something
like that happen holy [ __ ] man I wonder
if you saved the girl's life that night
you took the wrong drink and then you
were roofied instead of her
yo probably man you're a [ __ ] hero
that probably maybe that that is what
happened because I remember going to
another table with a bunch of dudes and
I was drinking some drinks mmm maybe you
save somebody dude what accident
yeah oops oops if you're out there and
you're watching this you owe me why do
welcome that's why I definitely checked
everything and I definitely checked my
ass
I definitely like like straight-up legit
but dude you know my friend who you went
to so he went to Vegas for a bachelor
party and he told me that so the next
day he woke up with the receipt in his
pocket
and it was I forgot what the amount was
but it was an absorbent amount and
margins guys not rich but his credit
card was torched for like let's just say
one ticket had like two grand and the
other one had like three grand he's like
what the [ __ ] happened right and so what
what we kind of figured out was that he
probably got [ __ ] roofied and so what
they said what happened was he says he
the last thing he remembered was him
come with was uh one of the like a
stripper came up to him and he started
pouring drinks down his throat and then
after that he blacked out
and so everybody told that yeah bro like
you you were kind of going ham and they
were pouring bottles of Cristal down
your throat and you know what at those
[ __ ] strip clubs like 300-400 bucks
each damn right 400 bucks or whatever
and it's just like charging it to his
card and he goes dude I don't know what
the [ __ ] happened goes how the [ __ ] did
I get charged for all the [ __ ] yeah and
they were just [ __ ] giving him random
drinks all night and so they're doing
that sitting on his ass sitting on his
lap getting naked pointing down Tracy
pay for that [ __ ] and he woke up with
like this absorbent amount of [ __ ]
charges on his on his card oh man those
hustlers did to you man no no nobody
ever roofies me yeah I'm feeling left
out did mine was accidental man sure no
one was like that guy I'm gonna get him
it was probably just like oh [ __ ] I took
it if there's like a CCTV of you sitting
down and the guys the guys just [ __ ]
sad he's like [ __ ] I only have one girl
and then you're sexually harassing him
okay I'm okay that's actually pretty
funny that'd be [ __ ] hilarious
in so dammit yeah I don't think I've
ever really blacked out before I mean
I've had I have moments where I had
splotches in my memory same here
right here blacking out completely but
like there's like a deleted long yes in
my memory has never heard like a long
chunk of time that's just like it's
bizarre for me because I know how much I
was drinking yeah exactly and so I I
know it was something well I had a sin
Foos recently where I got blasted drunk
and uh yeah there's like moments where I
don't remember like I don't remember
trying to [ __ ] a roundhouse kick some
water bottles off of this pole like I
don't remember that [ __ ] but I do
remember a majority of the stuff that
happened I know how I got to my hotel
yeah I know that
I woke up in my drunken stupor I try
eating a sandwich a cold sandwich off
the floor I remember I remember these
things it was this Primanti sandwich and
I guess like the back was okay I guess
it fell on before I was just there and I
was so drunk I was like I need something
in my stomach that should have been part
of the same foods episode they should
have recorded that and dog I was so
[ __ ] Smith I'm not saying this like
I'm proud don't yeah I was disgusted on
myself but it was to the point where I
was cognizant enough where I hated the
way I was feeling so all I was saying
repeatedly in the bed was I'll tell you
my drunkness to go away like it will
pass okay well I just needed somebody
the stroke my head it will pass but
that's how I get when I'm drunk because
I can't process it very well yeah it
hurts me yeah I'm good off of maybe like
three drinks that's why when you take
pepcid it slows down the it slows down
the breaking down of the alcohol oh so
goes through your system a lot slower
oh but the downfall is because it does
that just smash towards the other the
next day when you wake up right you're
still good you let's say you eat
something then your body starts
metabolizing everything then it starts
metabolizing that how call that was
inside oh [ __ ] and then you start
getting [ __ ] out oh I see I can and
then it's just like you wake up you're
like you eat like a bowl of ramen you're
like see I have to know this and I
should know this about myself it's eat
first before you drink right and then so
don't do it on an empty stomach
we're like middle schoolers talking
about yeah and then only have you could
have either three mixed drinks or you
can have four to five shots I should
know this but what happens is when we
have great conversation with somebody
we're just chilling you want me to go
get I'll get next round I'll get next
round then all the sudden I'm six drinks
in it's impossible to say no to you cuz
you having such a good time yeah that's
why you gotta just and I'm not feeling
drunk yet until the hour later yeah when
I'm [ __ ] looking for a hug in Prince
Street pizza and I'm hoping you're just
stumbling all across New York I'm like
[ __ ] am I drunk I [ __ ] up again
I get so upset with myself we're in New
York did you guys stay on the Lower East
Side
oh dude me too it's not well hotel where
you guys at uh twin sister or sisters
twin sisters in like that school thing
it's like a really modern smoky big nose
are [ __ ] small but it's really modern
and it's nice ladies fun out there man
it's cool I don't know if I could live
there I mean a Lower East Side I can
live yeah yeah I think when it gets a
little too crazy out there I don't know
about that [ __ ] because well even though
there's a lot of areas that are
gentrified when its hood in New York
yeah it's all crazy hood dude like I'm
clutching my purse immediately I'm like
the [ __ ] out of here and yeah cuz we
were we I forgot we were walking around
and it was daytime and I'm still scared
like is not for me it still sketch this
is not for me we got many uh projects
coming up um I have things that are
coming out um I'm in the purge the purge
is coming out soon TV show yeah this
character is interesting too because um
you know he's the whole premise is that
it takes it talks about the days leading
up to the purge right okay and and what
happens between purges mm-hmm so it
really analyzes like what how characters
think about these kind of laws that that
that that are like you know in society
where like you have one day to release
everything and people and so it's cool
to play this character where like you
know he's like he's just like a normal
good kid but he has a lot of anger and
he wants to let it out on a specific day
and so it's cool to like just see this
guy just you know he's just following
the rules this is what it is and then
one day the thing is the murder disorder
for sure if I was in a purge bro I'm
hiding immediately dude me too man [ __ ]
that [ __ ] my whole paycheck is gonna go
into building the shelter where's the
[ __ ] in impenetrable someone's gonna
figure out a way oh we would like to see
because if you do come in six rocket
launchers are coming out it'll be
someone that's like in your inner circle
you know you're hiding with like your
buddy Oh nobody's allowed in except for
me it's just you yeah all of you figure
out I'm surviving this [ __ ] dude that's
smart that's the smartest way man I got
bags of Kit Kats beef jerk
and a lot of porn I'm [ __ ] fine it's
only one day I'll just jack off and have
some strawberry KitKat's I'm good to go
you sons of [ __ ]
nice I know I got some hate in my heart
though dude if we had a purge day
there's a lot of people saying a lot
there's a couple of people that might
die immediately I just see you like
slapping them really hard just like
slapping or knocking him out you know
not kill him I don't think you're a
killer no no you just hurt them you know
I have hate in my heart but I'm not a
murderers yeah murders and a lot of the
times like the people I really dislike
it's not that I I dislike them but not
enough to hurt them dude you sort of
kill them with your words yeah you know
you're really good at it yeah yeah
there's some people whose career I want
to destroy just because they're trash
human beings but other than that it's
like uh no I don't really need to sleep
over it not worth it I'm pretty much
good to go well [ __ ] man it's already
time Dan that's it that was like that
was quick fun man yeah man well Lawrence
where can they find you on a diam
Lawrence count or on your televisions
all right yeah well check Lawrence out
one of my really good friends out in LA
you'll see him everywhere man I'm
talking about you want to talk about
good actors right there's [ __ ]
record in this [ __ ] right here
get on his [ __ ] level you stupid
[ __ ] not now yeah man well you could
catch us on any platform that's audio
and [ __ ] podcast related I say curse
a lot in between words when I blink out
it's a good recovery method it is so we
have so you can check us out on Spotify
stitcher just every audio platform
especially specifically iTunes podcast
give us that five star and you smell the
[ __ ] we'll see you all next time
peace out peace